>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Janice Hyde: Good afternoon.
Welcome to the John With.
Kluge Center at the
Library of Congress.
My name is Janice Hyde, and
I am privileged to serve
as the interim director
of the Kluge Center.
Before we begin today's
program, please take a moment
to silence your cell phones
and other electronic devices.
Thank you.
I'll also make you aware that this
afternoon's program is being filmed
for placement on the Kluge
Center website as well
as on its YouTube and
iTunes channels.
The John W. Kluge Center is pleased
to host this afternoon's program,
which will showcase the work
of one of its resident fellows.
The Kluge Center is a vibrant center
for scholarship on Capitol Hill
that brings together
intellectuals and researchers
from around the world to exchange
ideas and learn from one another,
to distill wisdom from the Library's
rich collections, and to interact
with policy makers in the public.
The Center offers opportunities
for senior scholars
and post-doctoral fellows to do
research using the vast collections
of the Library of Congress.
It also offers free public
lectures, conferences, symposia,
and other programs, and it
administers the Kluge prize,
which recognizes outstanding
lifetime achievement
in the humanities and
social sciences.
To view past programs or to learn
more about the Kluge Center,
please visit our website
at LOC.gov/Kluge.
Today's program is
entitled Popular Politics
and Public Opinion in
Late Medieval Paris.
It features scholar and current
Kluge fellow, Michael Sizer.
Dr. Sizer is a historian with
interests in political culture
and philosophy, cultural
history, interdisciplinary studies
of literature and ideas, urban
history, the history of revolt
and revolution, particularly
appropriate today.
He received his PhD in medieval
French history from the University
of Minnesota in 2008, and during
his graduate studies he was also a
fellow of the [foreign language]
at the Sorbonne in Paris.
Dr. Sizer's research at the
Library of Congress has focused
on late middle ages in France,
one of the most tumultuous periods
in European political history.
It was a time marked by revolts,
riots, popular preachers,
processions, and other engagements
of the people in the political realm
that was unheard of in
previous times according
to one chronicler of the period.
In celebration of Bastille
Day today,
Dr. Sizer will discuss the popular
politics of late medieval Paris,
1380 to 1422, and what
bearing it may have
on the way we understand
popular political culture today.
Please join me in welcoming
Dr. Michael Sizer.
[ Applause ]
>> Michael Sizer: Hello everyone.
So thanks for being here and
thanks to the Kluge Center
for having hosted me
these past several months.
It's been a great experience.
I'd like to thank in
particular Travis Hensley,
Mary Lou Riecher [phonetic].
Also, Erica Spencer at
the European Reading Room
and also the Rare Books
Reading Room.
Staff and also the other fellows
who it's been really
fun to interact act.
It's really exciting to be able
to research in this setting
and give this talk here
with the Supreme Court
and the Capitol Building
out the windows.
You know, I think it has definitely
affected and inspired my thinking
on the very deep and long
history of the relationship
of governments to their people.
And everyone knows that the Library
is the best place in the world
to do research on the history of
the Americas or the United States,
but it's also the best place in
the U.S. to do European history,
and I feel very lucky to
have been able to do that.
I'm also very thrilled to be talking
on Bastille Day because I'm going
to be talking about other earlier
rebellious Frenchmen and Parisians,
and I promise you a
riot at a Bastille.
The Bastille survives this riot,
but it won't survive, obviously,
the one that we commemorate
today in 1789.
All right, to start with, let
me give you just one example
of a chronicler's description
of Parisian popular opinion
in the period under study.
In February 1383, at the
time of fiscal insecurity
and popular discontent
over taxation,
the Duke of Anjou [phonetic],
serving as regent of France,
unwisely decreed that a
new tax should be levied.
As part of the process of making
such a decree official required
that it be proclaimed publically,
royal officials searched
around for a town crier
to proclaim the tax
in the market places of Paris.
Fearing physical harm,
no one volunteered
until finally one man
agreed to do it in return
for a significant payment.
The chronicle of the monk
of Saint-Denis relates
what happened next.
Taking all precautions for himself,
the crier assembled the people,
first entertaining them with slick
words and then loudly proclaiming
that someone had stolen golden
plates from the king's palace
and that the king would
give praise and reward
to those who returned them.
And as he had excited
the crowd to laugh
at this almost unbelievable item and
seeing that the crowd was distracted
and engaged in many
uproarious conversations,
he quickly spurred his horse
and proclaimed that a tax was
to be raised the next day.
This unexpected news disturbed the
minds of those in the audience,
who filled the city
with vague rumors,
most saying it was a false
tale and other astonished,
waiting to see the outcome.
Thus, the spirit of rebellion grew,
and they bonded together using
terrible words, conspiring the death
of those who decreed the tax.
The conventional scholarly consensus
following Jurgen Habermas is
that one cannot truly
speak of a medieval public
and that a proper public
only developed
under the historically specific
conditions of the enlightenment
and that the political sphere was a
restricted one dominated by status
and spectacle prior
to the modern age.
The episode described here
however depicts a Parisian crowd
that was far from passive in
the face of official authority
in the public space and furthermore
that employed its own modes
of spreading information,
formulating opinions,
mobilizing and taking action.
The crowd here is also politically
sophisticated, able to understand,
sort, and evaluate
information easily
and is not fooled by
the crier's rouse.
Perhaps most interesting is that
the forces of authority know
that the crowd is this way and
that they are operating in a tense
and tenuous context, an unstable
situation out of their control.
This passage is by no means
unique, references to an active
and engaged Parisian populous
occur frequently in all sources.
Still, this is a rather typical
example of public opinion
in that we have, in that it
only provides just a hint
of a bigger picture and raises as
many questions as it does answers.
Many of our examples of a sort of
medieval popular political action
and public opinion
come in tantalizing
but incomplete chunks like this.
But at the same time, we
cannot ignore these hints
as they suggest a quite
different way
of how medieval politics
operated from the elite-centered,
top-down model that still
dominates the scholarship.
When hints such as these are
put together and aggregated,
we can get a clearer picture of
late medieval political culture
in which the popular class
has played a significant
and even decisive role.
This process of collecting and
making sense of little chunks
of evidence like this in order
to make a comprehensive
composite picture
of how these phenomena operated
has been what I've been engaged
at the Kluge Center for
the past several months,
and in my previous time
here, several years ago
and doing my dissertation
research and also
at the National Archives in Paris.
I have also been trying to situate
this evidence within a wider context
of late medieval political
action, one that incorporates
and explains popular involvement
in politics in a way that puts it
at the center of that
[inaudible] political culture.
This talk will present
some of the results,
which are still preliminary,
still being sorted
and figured out of this research.
So why late medieval Paris.
Let's have a nice picture of people
unloading boats on the Sienne.
Late medieval, by this I mean
14th and 15th Century Paris,
is a great place to look
if we want to answer
for some of these questions.
There are several reasons for this.
The city, likely the largest in
western Europe, was inhabited by men
and women throughout
the social spectrum
and thus offers an opportunity
to see how both elites
and non-elites participated
in politics.
As a center of learning with the
University of Paris, and as the site
of the royal government with
its army of scribes as well
as a commercial hub with
a thriving merchant class,
the city was unusually literate,
perhaps up to 20 percent or higher.
The time period was tumultuous,
featuring frequent revolts.
Major popular uprising
occurred in 1356 through eight,
1380 through 1383, 1413 and 1419.
Civil war from 1407 through 1435 and
occupation by the English from 1420
to 1435 in the context
of the hundred years war.
This [inaudible] was both cause
and result of an unusual degree
of engagement in political
life by the popular classes,
and the question of their
involvement was hotly debated.
From a broader perspective, this
period is crucial, in the formation
of the French nation state as the
power of impersonal institutions
of authority were advanced
alongside the king's direct rule
and the integration
of the popular classes
when political society
was both a source of power
and disruption for
the expanding state.
Paris, as capitol of one of
the largest of these new forms
of centralized state, was
a vital stage for the play
of these new forms
of political power.
Furthermore, this period's
history of popular opinion
and politics is a particular
interest
as it predated the invention of the
printing press and yet displays some
of the features of political culture
associated with post-print era.
Political pamphleteering,
popular participation, propaganda,
lots of P's, and ideological
debate in all 14th
and 15th Century Paris is
an excellent laboratory
for observing premodern,
preprint popular politics.
So I struggled to think of various
ways, points of entry to explain
in this short lecture
the rather complicated
and broader political culture
that contextualizes all the
examples I want to show you
and that also could allow
me to bring to the fore some
of the bigger historical
and theoretical issues
that are related to this inquiry.
I think the best way to
do that is to go over some
of the late medieval meanings
and associations connected
to the key words in this
discussion, the people, populous
or [foreign language] and public.
Let's start with people.
The word populous has a long
history, stretching back to Rome
where it generally referred to
the populous Romani [phonetic],
the mass of male citizens where
authority was thought ultimately
to rest, but which by the
imperial period was seen
as a largely abstract entity with no
active force in political affairs.
The [foreign language] of Justinian
[phonetic] from the sixth century,
which would become quite influential
on late medieval law defines the
people as indicating the entirety
of citizens including patricians
and senators, while other terms
such as vulgus [phonetic]
or plebeians denoted
solely the lesser multitude.
This meaning continued into
the medieval period although
to this sense was added the
sense of a mass of believers,
the populous could be
the Christian flock.
In both cases, they are passive.
They're presence as a crowd
validates the authority
of the powerful one who was before
them, whether prince or priest,
who was acting upon them and
who was thus distinct from them.
It's main meaning was
to denote a mass
of undifferentiated
citizen subordinates.
The sense of the term essentially
persisted throughout the middle
ages, but in the late
medieval period,
a new set of associations
was added to it.
In some ways this borrowed from
the ancient Roman republican idea
that the people were the
ultimate source of sovereignty.
Late medieval jurists and
political thinkers such as Marsilius
of Padua [phonetic] and the
influential Bartolus of Saxoferrato,
who derived their arguments from
Roman law placed sovereignty
in the populous although the
implications of this were variable.
In general, though condemnation
of tyranny were well articulated
and abundant in medieval
political theory,
most medieval jurists
stopped short of saying
that the people could overthrow
an unjust prince, arguing instead
that resistance must be
undertaken in the words of Aquinas,
who is representative of
the commonly shared view
of medieval intellectuals, "not
through the private presumption
of a few, but rather
by public authority,"
meaning barons, lords, etc.
I don't want to get too far
into medieval resistance
theory here except to say
that unlike what is
sometimes assumed,
the middle ages produced abundant
and very varied versions of it
and that several were based on
the premise that ultimately care
and concern for the people was an
important if not fundamental factor.
This was accompanied in the late
middle ages by an ethic of sympathy
for the suffering of the poor
found in all sorts of sources.
The common saying [inaudible], the
voice of the people is the voice
of God, first attested by
Charlemagne's court advisor,
Alcowen [phonetic],
who was denouncing what he
said was a commonly held idea,
reflected a sort of sacred
power of the people's judgement.
Supplicants in pardon letters
from late medieval France
characterized themselves
as "poor laboring men."
In order to elicit sympathy,
royal decrees often declared
that the king is issuing
a law due to having heard
"the cries of the people."
Chroniclers often deplore
the suffering of the poor
and [foreign language], the lesser
people, to indicate the plight
of the realm and as an
implicit critique of leadership.
The Bourgeois of Paris, the name
given to an anonymous chronicler
of 15th century Paris, who was more
likely a cleric than a Bourgeois,
invokes the pathos of the suffering
poor frequently in his account.
Here is one example.
Alas. The great pity of going
through the city of Paris
because truly one could see more
men asking for alms than anyone else
who cursed their lives 100,000
times per day, in crying often
and assuredly in a raised voice,
alas, alas, true and gentle God,
when will you stop for
us this heavy sadness
and this melancholy life
and this damned war.
Note how the alas of the Bourgeois
is immediately echoed by the cries
of the impoverished Parisians.
The chronicler and the [foreign
language] speak with the same voice.
When he wants to condemn the
duke of Berry [phonetic],
who had joined the [foreign
language] party hostile
to the more popular, especially in
Paris, Burgundian [phonetic] party
in 1412 during the civil war, the
Bourgeois says, "He was more cruel
to the little people than any
serasan [phonetic] tyrant."
Political theorists
writing advice for princes,
called mirror of princes literature,
also argued that the protection
of the poor was crucial
to valid and proper rule
and even stressed the
common humanity under god
that both kings and peasants shared.
The most poignant example I found
of this, though there are several,
comes from a text I read
in February in the Library
of Congress' Rare Books Room,
and it's from the [foreign language]
information for kings and princes,
which is a late 14th
century French translation
of an earlier Latin text written
by an anonymous Dominican.
In a section on royal clemency and
dealing with recalcitrant serfs,
it says, and this is somewhat hasty
and rough translation, "To serfs,
one must not place punishment
with too much rigor but gently.
Because even though they are
serfs, they are God's creatures,
and in this we must consider
them as men and as friends
because we are all formed
from the same elements
and have the same birth.
We are called to the same heaven,
and we are from the
same blood, redeemed.
We all have a faith and a mind,
and we all go to the same purpose.
There is not serf or freeman
in God, and we are all of God.
Though I find this to be
an exceptionally eloquent
and poignant expression of
this idea of a common humanity,
the sentiment was not unique
and became an increasingly important
idea in the late middle ages,
helping validate the inclusion
of the people in political life.
This phenomenon should be seen
alongside an increased evaluation
of vernacular written culture,
which signaled the moving away
from the more exclusive clerical
culture of the earlier period.
Okay. So what is the
medieval idea of the public.
The most important thing
to remember is that while
in modern speech the
opposite of public is private.
In medieval parliaments, the
opposite of public, publica,
publicus, public [phonetic]
was singular or particular.
This reflects a different
nuance of the word's meaning.
In the middle ages public meant
pertaining to all or common
with its opposite particular meaning
pertaining to one individual.
A prostitute was a public woman
because she made herself available
to all, this is the real
meaning of a common woman,
rather than to a particular husband.
Chronicler [inaudible]
articulates this difference clearly
in his condemnation of the
behavior of rival court factions.
"Rivals in the civil war
induced him, the king,
to do their singular
will and pleasure
without having regard
together through deliberation
for the public good of the realm."
This last quote includes the most
common usage of the word public
in the later medieval period, that
of the public good or common good.
This concept came from Aristotle,
whose works were translated
into Latin in the 13th Century
in French and the 14th Century,
and the influence of
Aristotle can't be understated
in the late Middle Ages.
By the late Middle Ages the term
or common good was ubiquitous.
Late 14th Century poet Ustach
Deshawn [phonetic] provides
as good definition as
any in one of his poems.
What is the common good?
That which can relate to the
profit of all, young and old,
to keep the law his
country and his own.
Nichola Arem [phonetic], who
translated Aristotle's politics
into French in the 1370's and who
also glossed the text explained
"The common good is also like
a collective holy thing."
On the one hand, the
concept of the public
or common good justified
the increase of royal power
over a much greater
slice of political life
than had been possible before.
Indeed by the late Middle Ages the
French royal government had attained
both the ideological and
logistical authority and power
to make it the unquestioned center
of the realm's political universe.
In the late Middle Ages into the
growing influence of Roman law,
royalist medieval jurists
and thinkers were successfully
advocating for a conception
of royal sovereignty that was
stronger and more centralized
than previous, adapting the
Roman law formula to argue
that [inaudible], the king,
his emperor, and his realm,
enabling the application
of wide-ranging Roman imperial
powers encoded in law to the king.
This was accompanied by the growth
of impersonal, bureaucratic,
financial and legal
institutions of royal government,
which enabled extensive war
powers, coaptation of local courts,
the extension of a concept of
treason, and the implantation
of permanent royal taxation
in the mid-14th Century.
The idea of the public good was
mobilized for this purpose as well,
justifying the king's
abrogation of local rights
and prerogative in favor of his own.
Every encroachment,
taxation, expanded war powers,
overturning unfavorable
judgments in local courts,
ignoring municipal liberties
could be and was justified
by invoking the public good.
The kind and his royalists
theorists did not have a monopoly
over this concept however for
the public good could be invoked
against the king to
criticize his actions
and to invalidate his decisions.
The chronical of Jean Jouvenal
des Ursins gives but one example,
when Parisians reject
a tax levy in 1405.
In this time, one spoke loudly of
the queen and my lord of Orleans,
saying that it was by them that
lump-sum taxes (tailles) were made,
and sales taxes (aides)
raced about and were raised
without anything being done and
none of it used for the public good
and quite loudly in the streets once
cursed them and said many words.
As this example shows, the king and
his court could be held accountable
for their failures to uphold the
public interest while claiming
extensive powers allowed for the
royal government to assume a greater
and greater share of political life,
it also meant that they were subject
to public scrutiny to a
greater degree than before.
The king's morality,
disposition, and comportment
because his office was
central to the maintenance
of the public good became
objects of scrutiny and censure.
The thriving mirror of prince's
literature commented extensively
on the importance of the king
maintaining his moral character
as this was linked to the
performance of his public office.
Cruelty, gluttony, and other sinful
behaviors were not just a question
of personal salvation anymore
but were of public importance.
The court in particular was
a flashpoint for criticism.
Though the king's person
was sacrosanct
and he was rarely the
object of direct criticism,
his officials were not,
and they were often blamed
for the king's conduct
or for perceived failings
in royal governance.
Courtiers were frequently the
target of popular uprisings.
The most blatant example
of this in Paris is
when the revolutionary
provost of merchants,
the head of the Parisian
municipality elected
by the town's bourgeois, Etienne
Marcel gathered a crowd of men
who burst into the Palace [phonetic]
Royal, and this is early 1358,
and while the regent Charles
cowered in the corner in horror,
slaughtered his two leading marshals
before his eyes, one on his bed,
the victims' were decapitated,
then dragged out of the palace,
leaving blood all over the royal
chambers and stairs and display
in the courtyard visible
from the regent's window.
Marcel, whom one chronicler says
claimed-- oh here's a picture of it,
this is a modern representation
of the killing of the,
you can see the [inaudible]
how he's like sat,
and that's Marcel pointing.
Marcel, whom one chronicler says
claimed to have acted "concerned
for the public good" explained
to the cowering [inaudible]
that the killings of these
"false, wicked" traders was done
"by the will of the people."
These actions were a display of
the power of the commons intended
to intimidate as when
Marcel warns the [inaudible]
that the marshals were killed
to avoid greater perils.
Here's a picture of
Etienne Marcel's revolt,
and he's having the
Parisians clear the Louvre
of weapons during his uprising.
So potent was this dynamic
that it became the engine
for late medieval political
intrigue, those courtiers
who are marginalized in the constant
scramble for courtly prestige
and access to the king
and the decision making
and revenue controlling areas
of government could go outside the
court and appeal to the public.
They usually did so on the grounds
of immorality and the misuse
of public funds by court insiders,
which the populous was
only too happy to support.
The result was a recurring
cycle of scandal and purge
in late medieval France, a source
of considerable instability
in the government and discord
in the realm as a whole
and generally the defining
feature of most revolts.
In this way, the popular element
and it's sense of guardianship
over the public good was a central
feature of the politics of the day
in a way that is underappreciated
in most scholarship,
which focuses on the rivalry and
decision making of powerful figures.
All right.
So that's kind of the context
that I feel is important,
and I tried to make that as short as
possible because now it's more fun,
we're going to talk about
some of the examples.
What forms of popular political
expression are revealed
in the sources?
There are many different
types, and I will not be able
to discuss them all today.
For the sake of easy comprehension,
I divide them in what I'm trying
to write, into two categories, the
formal, the listed, the official,
and the informal, listed,
and unofficial.
Forman or official modes
of expression were
those generally overseen
or favored by forces of authority.
Informal or unofficial ones were
generally outside of their control,
and sometimes operated
against their wishes.
In the formal category, we
have, among other things,
representative bodies, such as the
estates general, the municipality,
petition, processions
and ceremonies,
moral and political
literature, and sermons.
In the latter category, the
informal, we have rumors, speech,
news, songs and festivals
plotting and revolt.
It should be noted that these
categories are not hard and fast.
Many of these elements listed
here, festivals for example,
could fall into both categories
depending on the situation,
and many of them overlap.
Municipal institutions could
often express the interest
of their community through
petition for example.
I just grouped them there for
the purposes of discussion.
In the interest of time, I
don't want to cover the formal,
official modes of communication
today.
The only thing I want to say about
them, and it is an important thing
to keep in mind, is that
although these modes
of interaction were
generally overseen by royal
or aristocratic officials
and those allied with them,
it does not mean they were fully
predictable or controllable.
We see that petitions from various
interest groups had a real effect
on royal legislation, which often
reproduced verbatim the petitioners
words and royal decrees.
Processions and ceremonies were
often carefully orchestrated
and extravagant spectacles,
but they relied
on the audience's participation
and bestowal of good graces,
which in some cases
was not forthcoming.
Crowds could confront the
king with petitions, heckle,
and simply not participate
in the expected numbers
or with palpably luke-warm
enthusiasm,
which was recorded by chroniclers.
As much of these events represented
opportunities for the powerful
to display and enact their power,
they were seen by the people
as a rare chance to have an
exchange with their sovereign.
So let's talk about some examples.
Let's talk about speech.
As stated before, though late
medieval Paris was unusually
literate, the predominant mode
of communication was oral.
Parisian's were famous
for their speaking.
The Duke of Berry [inaudible]
grumbles in 1413
that they are a "people
full of rumor."
And famed 15th Century poet,
Francois Villon declared
"there is no tongue
like the Paris tongue."
The oral public's fear has
several differences compared
with that dominated by writing.
Speech acts are bound by space and
time, which reduces their effect
and makes them subject to
immediate place of power.
The oral sphere is more determined
by the social differences
and personal charisma
of those occupying it.
But it's ephemerality
also raises possibilities
as it is more elusive and fluid.
From the modern perspective, we
tend to see written communication
as democratic and connected to the
greater possibilities of expression.
In the late middle ages, however,
writing was not democratic
and often served to calcify
and domesticate the thriving
oral-based exchange mechanisms.
Let's look at some examples.
Keep in mind it is rare
to have the contents
of speech acts although I have
a few of those rare examples,
but other examples allow us to
see hints of their form as well
as their ubiquity and importance.
So I want to go back to
the monk of Saint-Denis
for my first example here.
I really like this one
because of its sonic imagery
and the way it describes
and mobilizing crowd.
This is kind of similar
actually to the one,
and it's from the same revolt,
the mallet wielder's [phonetic]
revolt in March 1382 as before.
So the riot that he's
about to describe began
with the rough treatment of
a woman selling water crest
in the la saille [phonetic],
the city's marketplace,
by a royal tax collector.
Seeing this, the Paris crowd
beat the tax collector to death.
From this small incident,
the uprising grew rapidly
throughout the city,
represented in [inaudible]
chronicle, the monk's chronicle
by the cries of the people.
This crime having been perpetrated,
the tumult now could not
sustain itself in the marketplace
but soon pervaded all the city.
From all places one ran to the
marketplace with immoderate haste,
converging from all
directions into a crowd.
A loud clamor with a raised up from
everywhere and resounded in all ears
so that the dire venom of sedition
could be spoken everywhere,
next some men with
confused minds and deserving
of divine punishment went through
the neighborhoods and crossroads
of the city shouting out horrible
words equipped with the weapons
and swords that the popular furor
could supply, calling "To arms
for the liberation
of the fatherland."
This is the Maillotins Revolt.
It's called that because the rioters
went and got a bunch of hammers
that were stored in the city's
arsenal, and so they used hammers,
which were decidedly
nonaristocratic weapon.
Knights used swords.
And so they used hammers
in their revolt,
and here's them hammering
people and things.
The people expressed the
power of their numbers
and their uniformed
will to the loudness
of their collective shouting
because this power went as far
as shouting distance
combining with cry, the cry,
with movement to their city
spaces expanded their reach
of the people in rebellion.
So that's an example of
the power of the sort
of oral community has
expressed in this chronicle.
It's a rather extreme example.
What were the regular channels
by which information circulated?
Marketplaces such as the
aforementioned [inaudible], taverns,
prominent city squares,
bridges, cemeteries,
and churches were common
meeting places
where ideas were frequently
exchanged.
Instructions for town criers,
who were to disseminate orally the
king's decrees indicated the places
in Paris where the greatest
number of people congregated
and thus the announcements
would have the greatest effects.
These were before Saint
Genieve's church--
[ Foreign Language ]
Before the palace, before
the chateleigh [phonetic]
in LaSailles [phonetic] at Port--
[ Foreign Language ]
And so on, a letter of
remission describes how
in July 1413 during the
[inaudible] uprising
in Maillot [phonetic] near Paris
a chamberlain and a companion
"went together to the gate of
the market to hear the news."
Orem's [phonetic] translation of
Aristotle's politics mentions how
"all manner of people converse
in the market and in the city,
and because of this congregations
and assemblies are easily made."
Hers a marketplace picture.
Here's men discussing the
purchase of an Oxford.
Maybe they're also discussing
politics at the same time.
To this quote of Aristotle's
that Orem translates,
he also adds a grumbling gloss,
warning of "the mob or a multitude
of merchants found in marketplaces."
Taverns were particularly rife
with gossip, rumor, and discussion.
Here's a tavern.
Guilbert de Metz' [phonetic]
15th Century description
of Paris said there were
4000 taverns in the city.
There probably weren't that many.
And here are few sample tavern
names, just because they're fun.
The deer's horn, the Griffin,
the helm, the armed man,
the striped assistant, the
two axes, the three axes,
the bear on the line
and the wolf's tail.
So these people would congregate
in these taverns with their names
and their beautiful signs
that depicted these
things I just described.
The point is that these were all
important places where people
of all social strata mixed and
normal cultural codes of honor
and respect for hierarchy
were loosened.
Not surprisingly, some of the most
shocking and subversive snatches
of everyday people's
speech that comes down to us
in the sources were spoken
in taverns and then recorded
when their unfortunate speakers
went on trial for their words.
Here are some examples.
These are my favorites.
In 1379, Jean Loast [phonetic]
declared that he wished
"that the king was dead and
that his soul in paradise
and happy peace could be throughout
the realm, and it was a sin
that he continued to live."
In 1398, a certain Jean de
Begne [phonetic] was accused,
as it turns out falsely, of
having complained of over taxation
and called the king insane, and
he said that the king's brother,
"played dice and loved
whores," which was true.
My favorite example comes not
from Paris but from Orleans,
but I included it anyway
because it's too good.
In 1384 in the aftermath
of failed revolts
that shook the entire realm
including Paris and Orleans,
Guillium Lejup Onye
[phonetic], the roadmaker, said,
"Shit on this king
and shit on that king.
We have no king but God.
Do you think they acquired
what they have justly?
They burden me again and
again, and it weighs on them
that they can't have
all of our things.
What affair is it of theirs to take
that which I have gained
with my sewing needle.
I would rather have the
king and all kings die
than to have my son hurt
even his pinkie finger.
Do you think it was a good
idea for Guillium to say that?
No. He was pardoned actually,
but he got a fleur de li
[phonetic] engraved in his forehead.
The royal symbol, the fleur de li.
The authorities knew of subversive
speech prevalent in taverns.
The Duke of Burgundy, Philip the
Bold tried to use the network
of Paris taverns to his advantage
around 1400, "to put the hearts
of the people against
the queen and the Duke
of Orleans, the king's brother.
He had false lies spread
by scults [phonetic]
and in taverns about them."
A systematic regime of
espionage in the taverns of Paris
to prevent the youth from
plotting or being idyll,
for this led to revolt, was
advocated by a political philosopher
and some called the proto-feminist,
Christine de Pizon [phonetic].
She was maybe a proto-feminist
depending on your view,
but she was not politically
progressive in other ways.
And this plan was once again advised
by the Arman Yacklad [phonetic]
government in October 1413
after the [foreign language]
uprising had been quelled.
They say that "the provost of
Paris should send 30 or 40 good
and sure sergeants to walk often
around the city and in taverns
and other places to listen, inquire,
search and hear if they find
or know anybody murmuring, plotting
betrayal, saying or doing anything
that could be the cause
of disruption of peace."
The 1383 Parisians planned
for resistance as well
as an abortive 1417
plot to open Paris
to the Burgundians were hatched
in taverns, is tangible evidence
that the authorities
were right to be wary.
In addition to these informal modes
of spreading news and information,
more formal modes of
speech also existed
in these faces in the street.
Popular preachers commonly
circulated through Paris competing
with street performers,
peddlers, and the cries of sellers
of all sorts of wares for attention.
Most street preachers were connected
to an official organization,
and the right to preach
was officially guarded only
for those sanctioned by the church.
The university had a powerful
weapon to move public opinion
with its phalanx of preachers
from the student body and faculty.
This university preacher brigade
was a powerful and important tool
of the secular authority
such that the threat
of a preacher strike
was a major weapon
of intimidation by
university officials.
Also, the king found himself
frustrated in keeping the university
in line ideologically and was forced
to issue what were most
likely ineffectual warnings
against the university's preaching
when he found himself at odds
with their political views, most
notably in the twist and turns
of the policy of the subtraction of
obedience towards the [inaudible],
papal schism, it's a real
mess, but when the king
and the university disagreed with
one another, university would preach
against the king's policies.
One prominent popular
Parisian preacher, theologian,
Pierre-aux-Boeufs,
here's a preaching scene.
This is actually January
Husband, it's bohemia rather
than Paris, but I like the picture.
One prominent Parisian preacher,
theologian Pierre-aux-Boeufs
complains of the way that he has
to compete for attention
in the city's streets.
"There are many who never tire of
listening for the length of a day
to the jokes and japes of a
performer and his game of pantomime
or to hear a prolix
[phonetic] romance.
" Because of this, preachers
had to adapt accordingly
and filled their sermons
with fiery images,
sometimes condemning
the rich and powerful.
In one of his sermons,
Pierre-aux-Boeufs deplores the
laziness and decadent clothing
of the rich and equated
poverty with holiness.
He further says, due
to their rapacity,
they (the rich) show
themselves hard, rigorous
and cruel towards the poor.
The hard and evil words of the
poor hear sometimes at the doors
of the greedy rich stripped of
all mercy, these harsh refusals
that they there can be called
rightly hard stones hurled at God.
The sources refer to the
presence of many preachers
who captivated the city for
months with their public sermons
on morality held in the streets
or Saint Innocence
Cemetery before great crowds
such as the Franciscan
brother, Richard, in 1429,
who was said by the bourgeois of
Paris to have drawn five to 6000
for his moralizing sermons.
When Brother Richard was
giving these sermons,
no doubt he had the famous
painting of the dance of death
for which Saint Innocence Cemetery
was well known for centuries
as his backdrop, reinforcing
the theme of the equality
of all human beings
before God and judgment.
Nonprofessional preachers
can get and audience.
[Foreign language] mentions, "A
crazy man captivated audience
in the Palace [inaudible]" in 1410,
claiming he could heal
the king's insanity.
The king was insane
from 1393 to 1422,
a long time, probably schizophrenic.
And that caused a lot
of problems too.
Aside from Brother Richard,
the bourgeois mentions the
well-attended preaching sessions
of a recluse named Jean La
Vouyeur [phonetic] in 1442,
and the Chatleigh [phonetic]
registers state
that [foreign language] would be
hanged as a thief in June 1390,
pickpocketed a woman
distracted "by a sermon"
at Saint Innocence Cemetery.
Political leaders would
sometimes give large speeches
to assembled crowds as well.
Recognizing their power, both sides
in the civil war employed
their own preachers.
Prior to this, there was the
remarkable speech war in 1357
and 1358 between Charles the
Bad of Navarre and his rival,
the [inaudible] regent Charles,
the same one who was cowering
in the corner earlier, later,
King Charles the fifth at the time
of the Etienne Marcel
uprising in Paris.
Charles the Bad had
scaffolding erected.
This is a picture of
this, supposedly.
It's kind of a strange picture,
but Charles the Bad had scaffolding
erected in the [foreign language],
an open field where normally
jousts and other events were held,
and had his men spread
word of the coming speech
in the days leading up to the event.
Around 10,000 are said to have shown
up at eight or nine in the morning
of November 30 to see the demagogic
Charles the Bad give a speech
railing against royal officers
and other injustices perpetrated
by the royal government for
Castro-esque four to five hours.
Not wishing to be outflanked, the
young dofan [phonetic] gave a speech
at the Palace de Grave [phonetic]
on 11 January to "a great crowd
of people" in which he declared
that he was "ready to live
and die" with the Parisians.
The speech worked.
"The words of the [inaudible]
were so agreeable to the people
that he had the greater part
of them in favor of him.
Another example of spreading
information and commentary
about contemporary
politics was through song.
Music was a major part of medieval
cultural life, and people played
and sang as a group activity
or enjoyed watching
street performances.
Because music and songs were part
of the people's participation
in political ceremonies, it
is not surprising to find
that music could be injected
with a different political
context out of satire.
A ruling from 1395 prohibits Paris
minstrels from singing "neither
in the squares nor elsewhere"
any [inaudible], rhymes or songs
that make mention of the pope,
king, or lords of France.
The monk of Saint-Denis
describes how some Parisians sang
"injurious songs" outside the window
of the Countess of Henolt [phonetic]
as she dined after arriving
to the city as an ambassador
for John the Fearless in 1414.
One chronicler in 1347 comments
that a song called "I Failed Her
to Whom I Was Given in Love"
was sung "everywhere in France"
about the young count of Flanders,
Louis, who abandoned his fiance,
the daughter of the King
of England at the altar,
thus touching off a
political scandal and war.
In 1413 in the context of the
vicious civil war in France,
a judicial record tells
that [foreign language],
who snuck into the town of
[inaudible] near Paris was arrested
for playing subversive songs
on his harp in a tavern
and for having a written
version of "A Ballad
Against Those in Paris"
in his pocket.
The printing press is given a lot
of credit for the role it played
in spreading ideas during the
reformation, and so it should,
but it is also important
to realize the elements
of pamphlet culture existed in
Paris before Gutenberg's invention.
The widespread use of paper, a
cheaper alternative to parchment,
began in the 14th century,
making writing more
disposable and accessible.
Orality retained its importance
in aspects of law and government
but increasingly writing
had become necessary,
rather than an ornamental
accompaniment to these procedures,
and have permeated
civic life as well.
It must be remembered that
in this period orality
and literacy were not mutually
exclusive worlds or processes.
Written texts were often
read aloud to audiences,
and thus a large amount
of people could share
in a textual experience
even if they could not read.
Political broadsides have been
discussed as a feature of English,
political and urban life as a
major vehicle for the spread
of the Lollard heresy
in the same period.
But it is almost certain that they
existed in France and Paris as well.
A few of them have come down to us
as they were designed as ephemeral,
but sources give several
indirect references to them.
The political debate
over the papal schism,
which fed into the
political disputes
of the civil war had occasion
efforts the control opinion in 1397
as this ordinance states quote that
"no person regardless of status
or condition be not so daring or
bold in secret or openly, directly
or indirectly in deed or
in speech to preach, orate,
make or write letters or any
other sort of writing or anything
that can bring or create any harm
or obstacle to the above said vote
of succession neither in the
manner or means to proceed
with it or in its practice.
Also, in 1406, anyone found
with a copy of a University
of Tulet letter arguing that the
king could be deposed as a heretic
if [inaudible] pope
was to be executed.
There was considerable
concern over seditious letters
in the civil war period,
and efforts were made
to intercept them before they
could reach their audience.
Such letters were probably intended
to be read in taverns and churches
by sympathizers, but copies
of them would also be hanged
up on church doors and other places
as Nichola de Bay's [phonetic]
description of a provost
of Paris decreed banning the
practice in July 1404 indicates.
The royal condemnation of the
Cabotian [phonetic] rebels
after the revolt was crushed
in September 1413 lists as one
of their major crimes that "many
defaming letters were made and sent
to many persons affixed to church
doors and published in many places."
Though he was considerably
well connected,
and that's not exactly a member of
the common people, it is noteworthy
that the Duke of Burgundy,
John the Fearless,
engaged in a large scale publicity
campaign directed by University
of Paris theologian John Petit
[phonetic] for his justification
of tyrannocide, a treatise
defending his recent assassination
of the king's brother,
that's the guy
who likes dice and
plays with whores.
Luxury copies donned in leather were
sent to prominent lords as gifts
from John the Fearless, but
cheaper copies were also produced
for distribution.
Petit and his secretary,
John Johannes [phonetic] used the
treasury office of the College
of Roueaux [phonetic]
of the university
for the copying campaign in 1408.
Twelve students at a time would
take dictation from Johannes
to produce numerous
additions, which were then sent
out throughout Paris and the realm.
I promised riots of the Bastille,
and I will deliver, but before that,
I think it is important to
remember that if we're talking
about popular resistance to a royal
authority, and not all, in fact,
not most of popular political
engagement was adversarial
to the crown must be said, even in
these tumultuous medieval centuries,
it is just as important however
to talk about more humble,
everyday forms of resistance
than big revolts.
Rather than take the
risk of open revolt,
townspeople from the Parisian
[foreign language] were most likely
to engage in the sort of everyday
resistance activities famously
analyzed by James Scott in the
study of modern Malaysian peasants,
foot dragging, dissimilation,
desertion, false compliance,
pilfering, feigned ignorance,
slander, arson, and sabotage.
By their nature, such acts are
likely to escape mention in sources,
but there are some references.
I think a most instructive
reference to kind of every day sort
of resistance that we encounter
comes from a July 1388 ordonnances.
Every day there is committed and
perpetrated many crimes, excesses,
evils, and ill deeds, and that many
times and often it has occurred
and occurs that some of
our Officers and Deputies
when the case requires it to
make rulings, enforcement,
or other matters of justice, have
rebellions, defiance, obstacles,
and disobediences given to them.
And what is worse, many of
our officers, procurers,
and sergeants in exercising
their said offices and duties
and otherwise, in hatred or contempt
of them, have been greatly injured
and cursed or very badly
beaten, mutilated, and wounded
and some dead and killed.
This comes in the context
of the crown attempting
to label royal officers in a legal
extension of the royal person.
Thus they personified the
king and therefore any act
on them was an act of treason.
We can see here once again that
the people obviously drew a clear
distinction in their minds
between king and officers,
a distinction that the crown tried
to erase but to little effect.
All right.
Riot at Bastille time.
Obviously the most sensational
and therefore most documented
expressions of popular politics
in this period were
instances of revolt.
As I mentioned earlier, these were
frequent in the late middle ages,
once generation in Paris.
Scholars [inaudible] in how and
what they mean and how we were
to compare them to modern-day
revolutions, and those are big
in great questions, but it
would take a whole other lecture
to begin to address them.
What I hope to do here is to
describe one riot that was part
of the 1413 Caboshian [phonetic]
revolt so you can get a picture
of what these events looked like
and some of the dynamics that were
in play that echo what I
have already talked about.
Briefly, the Caboshian revolt was
an uprising in which aristocrats,
university men, trade
gills, and rank
and file Parisians all participated
in a loose alliance based
on a common ideology of antagonism
towards the growth of taxation,
the state bureaucracy, and
the increased centralization
of government power in the court.
It took place in Paris in 1413.
It is named for Simon Cabosh,
the slaughterhouse worker,
who was one of the movements leaders
as it was the Paris butcher's guild
that was at the forefront
of the movement.
Following a contentious estate's
general meeting in January
and February in which the estates
rejected calls for taxation
and instead demanded reforms
and purges of wicked courtiers,
a commission was established
to draft a set of decrees
that would reform the
royal government.
This would be issued in May and is
now called the [foreign language].
In late April following the
riot I'm about to describe,
the Caboshian seized
power through the organs
of the Paris municipal government
and militia and by physical control
of the king, again, the
tragic Charles the sixth
who was incapacitated by
schizophrenia and the dofan,
the 13-year-old Louis
of Guien [phonetic].
Once in power, they purged the
government of disagreeable courtiers
and tried to win other cities
in the realm to their cause.
Alarmed by their excesses,
the University of Paris,
the Duke of Burgundy and other
initial sympathizers abandoned the
movement in July, and the
movement collapsed in August 1413.
So this is an incredibly complicated
history, but let's just focus
for now on the night of April 28.
On this night, the butchers,
as heads of the city militia,
rallied 3000 armed Parisians in
the Palace de Grev [phonetic],
entering the hotel
de Ville [phonetic]
and seizing the town standard
to leave them as they marched.
Over the course of the next several
hours, 20,000 more joined them.
These numbers are provided
by chroniclers,
and they are probably exaggerations.
A crowd of 23,000 would
represent at least 10 percent
of the Parisian population in this
time and would have been the size
of London's population by itself.
So these numbers, we have to
doubt, but in any case we can guess
that the participation
of everyday rank
and file Parisians was significant.
The monk of Saint-Denis Sandonen
[phonetic] describes the riot
as "the popular commotion
instigated by most sordid men
and later the participants as
plebeians and the popular classes."
Once assembled, the crowd
marched to the Bastille.
They did so because they knew
that Pierre de Czar [phonetic]
from a prominent Paris bourgeois
family and former provost
of Paris once popular but now
hated had taken refuge there.
The Bastille also had both tactical
and symbolic importance
to the city of Paris.
It had been constructed
here, we see it,
in the 1370's by Charles the fifth
and his authoritarian provost
of Paris, Ug O Brio [phonetic],
as part of that king's aggressive
building program intended
to assert symbolic royal
power and ownership
over the city's physical space
following the Etienne Marcel revolt
of 1356 to eight.
He was scarred for his
whole life by that incident
that I described earlier when the
marshals were executed in front
of him and he wanted to have
an extensive building program
that would kind of assert his power.
As an extension of the
Saint Antoine gate,
it was a key strategic
defensive threshold
between the city's interior
and exterior, which contributed
to the Parisians' concern
that it was being used
for a planned assault on the city.
So in 1789, the Bastille was
in the middle of the city.
In 1413, it was right
on the edge of the city.
For these reasons, the Bastille
was seen as an intrusion
on the Paris community
sense of peace.
When they arrived, the Parisians
camped out in front the fortress
and "swore an oath not to leave
until they had taken
the fortress by force."
Another chronicle says
that they threatened
to demason the fortress,
which I love.
I love that.
The angry crowd was
temporarily mollified, however,
and the Bastille given a 376 year
reprieve, when the Duke of Burgundy,
beloved by the masses arrived
and arrested Pierre de Czar.
The Parisians were
not done, however.
Still amassed and a large
crowd, the Parisians marched
to the dofan's residence at San Paol
[phonetic] and demanded an audience.
The dofan's counselors
advised him to charge
out his gates wearing
a Fleur de li flag,
but the teenage Louis could
not muster the courage to do
so against the armed and
angry throng outside.
He was 13.
It would have been hard.
The Parisians draped the city stand
over the fleur de li on the gate
of the dofan's residence.
The dofan Louis addressed
the crowd to his credit,
saying that they should
return to their jobs.
From the Roux St. Antoine,
Jean de Troyes [phonetic]
representing the Parisians
who cheered him on,
he was a surgeon,
and surgeons in those days
weren't the reputable doctors
that they became-- anyway, Jean de
Troyes announced that they had come
for the benefit of
the realm and demanded
that the dofan's wicked counselors
be delivered to them immediately,
producing a scroll of
50 named "traitors"
that they insisted the
dofan's chancellor read aloud.
They also attacked the
dofan's moral character saying
that he spent too much time in
"indecent nocturnal parties"
and that they feared that his
lack of guidance and discipline
in his youth would lead him to
the same sickness of his father.
They said that if the demands were
not met they would "rip everything
to pieces" and the dofan's hotel.
When the dofan's chancellor Jean de
Ville read the scroll of traitors,
the first name on it was his own.
At this, the dofan
withdrew into his residence
and refused any more discussion.
The Parisians immediately stormed
the dofan's hall by smashing
down the door and then "raced
through its halls in all directions
and rifled through all his records
and sized everyone they found,
sending many noblemen in
the dofan's court to prison.
The violence then spread throughout
the city as Parisians rounded
up other suspected
traitors and arrested them
and ransacked their homes.
Though the night of April 28
with an intense and extreme
in its confrontation
with royal authority,
in essence it's continued the
themes I have already tried
to explore today, and the animated
late medieval Parisian popular
opinion in my quiet times as well.
We see the Parisians
able to mobilize quickly,
probably through word of
mouth facilitated here
by the militia deputies
who could neighborhood
by neighborhood to spread the word.
But they also produced a scroll of
traitors showing their familiarity
with writing and the inner court
workings no doubt disgruntled
courtiers assisted them in
the drawing up the scroll.
We see the implicit claim to
represent the public good by arming
for the city's defense,
justified by their use
of the militia organization
and their marching behind the city
standard and also their desire
to remove threats to the city
by pulling suspected traitor,
Pierre de Czar from the Bastille.
We see them using claims of
the dofan's immorality as a way
to justify arrest of his courtiers
and curbs on his autonomy.
Through their physical
penetration of the dofan's hall,
we see them claiming the space
as subject to public scrutiny,
a public space rather than a
personal one of the dofan's.
We see from a broader lens this
crucial dynamic referred to earlier
that court intrigue could
be animated by alliances
with the popular classes.
In all, we see the most
spectacular manifestation
of what was a fundamental aspect of
late medieval culture, the central
and tumultuous role of the people
engaged in political action.
So, I'll stop there.
[ Applause ]
So, are there any questions,
anybody have any comments?
Yeah, sure, Tom?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Well thanks for that question.
I actually had a huge chunk on
Habermas that I removed just
because it wasn't working
for this lecture.
I wanted to talk about the sources.
And it's hard to answer
in a short thing.
But yes it's a big part of what
I'm going to try to talk about.
Habermas was very explicit
in that he said
that what he was describing was part
of a very contingent political
history, structural features
of the 17th century and
the 18th century in Europe,
and this was essentially that the
people, bourgeoisie especially,
could enter the public sphere,
they were private individuals
who could enter a public sphere as
a public people and voice their sort
of universal opinion using reason
in order to advance their opinions
in kind of a neutral
plane with everyone else.
The means for this was
in cafes and salons
and newspapers and things like that.
So the structural elements that
Habermas talks about were not
in evidence in the 15th
century, 14th century in Paris.
Although some of them were.
I mean, some sort of insipient
versions of that were.
And Habermas doesn't say
much about the Middle Ages.
He sort of hints at it.
Other people kind of coming after
him had filled that picture in,
but what Habermas does say is that,
oh gosh, there's so much to say.
I'm going to try to keep
this as short as I can.
He says that what's crucial
is that there is a line
between the government
and the people.
There's the government
and the civic society.
And what traditionally
people like Habermas
and other's says is the Middle
Ages didn't have that line.
The Middle Ages had all these
intermediate entities, lords,
other jurisdictions, and all of
these people so that the public,
what would be the public's sphere,
was filled by all these kind
of intermediate things,
and the medieval sort
of political story was thus not
one with a line between government
and people but actually a
whole bunch of nodes of power.
I think Habermas talked
about status, sort of walking
around with the nobility rather
than-- so that's Habermas' argument.
And he said what I'm
describing is not an ideal type
but a specific event.
A lot of people have
criticized Habermas.
I think that the best criticism of
Habermas is the feminist criticism
for example that points
out that what he describes
as a universal public sphere was
in fact very heavily gendered.
There were all sorts of rules of
playing in the public sphere that,
you know, they talk about
it being governed by reason
but in fact there are all sorts of
kind of social identity, related,
gendered things that
were restraining it.
And Nancy Frasier,
her argument's great.
And other people have
also come in, not just me
but other people have talked about
how there are many different kinds
of public sphere, you know, the very
thing that Habermas didn't want.
I have sort of articulated arguments
why there are actually many of them
and that Habermas is a little
too sort of Euro-centric and kind
of modern-centric in his thing.
What I would say against the still
strong and still potent argument is
that in the Middle Ages we see,
and I think the court is the key,
we see antagonists, people
defining themselves as subjects
and as marginalized from kind
of royal government as subjects,
and then the court is this object
of frustration, animosity, hatred,
and so in some ways you see
what Habermas was talking about,
which was a line between the
government and the people.
But this co-exists with all of these
other sort of political affiliations
that Habermas was talking
about, that people have talked
about since de Tokeville
[phonetic] and Marx, you know.
So, but I think that because
you do have those kind of,
that kind of dynamic between Court
and people, you are seeing sort
of this kind of early version
of people considering themselves
as a kind of a public
against the government.
Now is it governed by reason?
I think I've already answered
this question for a long time,
so I'm sort of reluctant
to be there.
No, I mean there was a sort
of, there was a culture
of reasonableness that people try
to advocate, but it wasn't as sort
of blown up, and it's
kind of celebrated
as it was in the enlightenment.
And I guess I would go back to Nancy
Frasier's argument and the argument
of others that this kind
of ethic reason was itself,
a kind of cultural construct that
couched and hid all of these kind
of sort of gendered and other ways
that there was excluded
and included people.
That was a long answer.
I'm sorry everyone, but
it's a really good question,
and it's really complicated stuff.
Did I kill every-- yeah?
>> [Inaudible] politics,
so but I notice
that [inaudible] royal taxation
would be a political issues
[inaudible] and so forth,
and I [inaudible] ever a
perceived public interest or, yeah,
public interest on the spending side
such that you would
find a tax ear marked
for a particular activity
[inaudible] or more acceptable
or less than the object [inaudible],
so on the spending side,
what was understood
to be [inaudible] a worthy activity
[inaudible] the subjects would kind
of go along, and the other
thing that I was kind of curious
about one might [inaudible]
conflicts is
to have a good [inaudible]
a good outside [inaudible]
and the English were sort
of [inaudible] and I kind
of wondered what role they played
either rhetorically or in actuality
as [inaudible] these
things, you know,
the French would put all [inaudible]
come together [inaudible].
>> Okay. Two good questions.
So the story of taxation is quite
complicated, but the original,
sort of medieval structure
of taxation as sort
of exactly what you're talking
about, that taxation had to be
for a specific purpose, and so
originally leaders would raise a tax
for building a wall, for
paying for my son's wedding,
for very specific purposes.
And for a war most often.
Okay. And so this was the
tradition, and leaders always had
to articulate what that purpose
was, municipal leaders had
was, and there was an expectation
of a kind of cause and effect.
In the 14th Century the
war became the hundred,
well the term the hundred years war
was a later term applied to the war,
but there was basically a kind
of endless war with the English,
and in the context
of the endless war
with the English there was
also an endless need for funds.
And so the French government,
the royal government kept collecting
money for war against the English
such that they just finally said
guys, let's just do this every year.
We always need money.
We're running out of money.
And when they tried to do that,
that's when the most serious,
I mean I would call it a revolution,
the Etienne Marcel uprising,
when the crown tried to
impose permanent taxation,
and it was in the king got captured
at the battle of [inaudible]
by the English, and
to pay his ransom
because the English extracted
a huge ransom for him.
The crown said we just
need huge amounts of money.
And in the face of that, Etienne
Marcel, the provost of Paris,
I mean the provost of merchants
in Paris, and the estates general,
you know, created a very significant
resistance reform movement,
and they tried to have the
estates government essentially,
state's general essentially
govern the country.
So the resistance to this kind
of permanent taxation was pretty
serious, and it was, they never,
they never stopped being serious.
I mean this taxation
problem continued.
What stopped it is kind of the
answer to your second question,
or what changed the game, which
is, after all of these revolts
that I'm talking about and
the civil war especially
between these two parties,
the Burgundians
and the Armonex [phonetic], so
kind of a complicated story,
but basically the Duke of Burgundy
assassinated the king's brother
in 1407, and these two
factions sort of fought,
and they fought for years.
When that happened, and with
all these revolts happening,
France was severely weakened,
and the English invaded
under Henry the fifth [inaudible]
1415, they occupied France
and northern France in 1420 an
in the treaty of Troyes in 1420,
Henry the fifth's son, Henry
the sixth, Henry the fifth
of England's son, was
to take over the crown
of France, so this was disaster.
And in this, and this
is happening, you know,
ten years after the
events I'm describing,
in this context you have the dofan,
who has got his little enclave,
and that's when Joan of Arc appears.
Okay. And I think you can say
that that changes the equation
for many Frenchmen and
that is the external enemy
around which they are
able to mobilize.
That being said, I always insist
that you must understand that even
with Joan of Arc, even with the
English occupying most of France,
that there were a lot of people in
France who we would call Frenchmen,
including the Parisians
most notably,
who didn't like Joan of Arc.
Joan of Arc was an Armonac, she
was kind of on the other side.
Joan of Arc was burned
by the Burgundians,
the English captured her but
handed her over to the Burgundians
to burn her, and so
this idea of Frenchness
that was being mobilized
successfully by the dofan
and by his party was eventually
able to kind of overcome some
of this kind of fractiousness,
but that even in Joan
of Arc's time it was
not a sort of done deal.
So, that was long answer too.
I'm trying to not have long answers.
Yes sir?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Well there's tons of popular
mobilizations in Europe.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
No, it's not unique, but
the university of Paris
in this period mostly because of the
papal, politics of the papal schism
in which there was a pope in Rome
and a pope in Avienne [phonetic],
became really, really
politically active and kind
of exercised its muscle more
than I think most university,
most universities and
other places did.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Well, I mean, so the University
of Tullos [phonetic] and the south
of France was kind of a very
different political context,
but the University of Tullos
issued what I described here,
this letter in 1406 saying
that the king was a heretic
for supporting the Aviennial pope.
So, yeah, they would get involved.
The University of Orleans would also
get involved in the uprisings there
in the 1380s and the Italian
universities, some of these jurists,
and I don't think they
weren't sort of directly
in the street the way the
University of Paris people were,
but a lot of their
jurists are articulating,
as I sort of alluded to,
justifications of government as,
you know, being based in the popular
sovereignty, and Marsilius of Padua,
you know, is the most sort
of strident version of that.
He basically kind of almost
a republican in this period.
But no, I don't think
overall it's nothing compared
to University of Paris.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Okay.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.